[Musique]
la flotte c'est tout
y'a rien alors là c'est totalement vide
[Musique]
un peu
j'arrive au rayon tous les gens ils sont
en train de tripoter la tomate c'est lé
pa ferme au bout de deux ou trois heures
la tomate et c'est invendable de
l'agencé parce que quand ils arrêtent
tout ça frigorifiés
[Musique]
on trouve sur les étalages la tomate
qu'on appelle tomates grappes qui est
une variété qui avait été sélectionnée
pour que les tomates mûrissent tout en
même temps sur la grappe
alors que sur les tomates anciennes
comme sur celle ci on voit bien que les
tomates mûrissent les unes après les
autres elles ont été sélectionnées pour
ça et pas du tout pour le goût c'est
uniquement le pédoncule que l'on voit
ici qui donne du parfum sur le sur
l'étal les arômes c'est finalement ce
qu'on perçoit quand on mâche un fruit
ce sont les odeurs qui vont remonter
dans le nez
[Musique]
un potager comme un verger c'est un acte
politique
un acte politique parce que s'assigne la
façon dont on vit aujourd'hui on est des
trios mais douceur en consomme on est un
monde où on prend on redonne peu et on
n'essaie pas de comprendre d'où ça vient
[Musique]